this video is brought to you by Rocky
money more on them after the reaction
peeps citizens of the reject Nation it
is time for a trailer I am very much
excited for Kung Fu Panda 4 if you guys
didn't know I covered the movies with
Coy jro right here on this very Channel
he was supposed to join me for this but
he decided to leave
town jerk jerk enjoying his holiday
season anywh who guys what did you think
about this trailer I haven't seen it yet
but I'm excited to see what your take is
on in the comments go head type it down
below be sure to leave a like that would
be very much appreciated all right I
haven't slept and my wife still told me
about this trailer she's awesome I love
her let's do
this it is time to take the next step on
your journey oh I'm excited I'm not
going to be the Dragon Warrior anymore
you will advance the spiritual leader of
the valley of Beast yes about like
oong inner peace keep your surf off my
cool dinner please dinner with peas in
a this is not working at
all yes I heard just coming back big
fan once I possess the Kung Fu of every
Master villain no one will dare question
my power not even the great wait Dragon
Warrior she said every Master V and most
powerful shape-shifting sorceress are
they all coming back how do I find this
the chameleon I'm going to lead you
right front door they always make for
great villains chameleons it was against
an
army then we'll just have to get an army
of our own I think Aquafina fits
perfectly into this world best Crooks
and criminals live here you're a wanted
criminal you sound surprised is it
surprising now you kids be careful of
those fireworks
yikes some more zootopia Vibes this time
around being the Dragon Warrior it's who
I
am about being a spiritual leader what
is it you're holding a cookie you were
chosen to become something more than you
already are the next
[Music]
Evolution this really feels like it's a
full circle movie quick and painless
or slow and painful let's
K you finally met your match
chameleon when not so different you and
I we're not so different you stand back
I'm going to kick my
butt oh it's got to change up the logo a
little
bit
it's going to be a cool
fight oh
no I'm excited for it
man can't wait to watch it I'm so
excited for it I really love the second
one's my personal favorite one of the of
the previous three but I I really
enjoyed all three of them all right
let's talk about it I got some thoughts
got some thoughts before that a word
from Mar monter hey reject Nation you
know running real rejects is an
incredible journey is something I am
truly grateful for but I got to be real
with you for one second here managing
the business side especially taxes to
put it lightly is incredibly
overwhelming it's like navigating a maze
without a map and that's where our
sponsor rocket money comes in a sponsor
when approached I was so excited to work
with because I kid you not just last
month I started using rocket money cuz I
needed to sort out this financial puzzle
and honestly it's been quite eye
openening not just for taxes but boy oh
boy that whole cliche of this app is
true I discovered apps and subscriptions
I have been paying for that I had not
used in ages it is like finding out
you've been leaving lights on in a room
that you never use so yes rocket money
isn't just another app it's like a
freaking Financial Guardian Angel it
finds and cancels those forgotten
subscriptions monitors your spending and
even battles to lower your bills thank
God it's as if they're personally
invested in saving your hard-earned
money like I try I really try to be on
top of my expenses but rocket money they
show me blind spots with a simple T I
can cancel unnecessary subscriptions
they even handle the hassle of
negotiating with customer services a
relief my goodness to put it into
perspective rocket money has helped over
5 million users save an average of $720
a year that's more than just numbers
it's a peace of mind so I invite you my
fellow rejects in taking control of your
finances so go ahead visit Rocky
money.com reject once again that's
rocket
money.com rejects let's save together
money.com rejects I really do stand by
this app thank you for partnering with
us all right well that was a really
really fun trailer had a great time
watching that one um I really feel like
this one's going to be a full circle
experience uh especially for our main
character po the fact that they're
bringing back TI long and seeing that
they're getting a new Dragon Warrior
which is an interesting plot point he's
becoming like oolong or Shifu for that
matter he's becoming the embodiment of
you know his Master she's going from
becoming you know just a student who was
discovered to becoming like the fullon
spiritual leader he's going to be
embodying the wisdom and experience he's
gained over time you KN so much about
the Kung Fu Panda films have also been
about him balancing his identity is both
a funloving panda and a formidable
Dragon Warrior but this new film looks
like it's going to be incorporating
those aspects a little bit more to where
he might become a more balanced and wise
leader and then having you know
characters like tied long returning it
seems like they're hinting at all of
them returning in some aspect could
allow for Resolutions of past conflicts
possibly through Redemption arcs maybe
which could in turn perhaps uh deepen
his relationship with his biological and
adoptive families it just seems like
overall we're going to be getting a full
circle experience justifying the
existence of a part 4 after so many
years because the Kung Fu Panda movies
have always been about you know selfis
Discovery self-acceptance and his
journey into becoming the new spiritual
leader essentially like the ultimate
Testament to his self accept acceptance
and understanding of his place in this
world and by finding and training the
next Dragon Warrior whoever that might
be maybe it's Aqua I don't know po
completes his journey by becoming that
Mentor figure akin to shiu passing on
that knowledge and embodying the cycle
of student becoming the master and then
you know that whole thing with like
influencing future Generations just as
as he was influenced by his predecessors
so sensely showcasing his Evolution from
like an enthusiastic dreamer to a wise
leader and you're fulfilling that
prophetic role he was unwittingly
destined for since the first movie I
mean it's Jack Black he hasn't lost his
touch with you know Voice work he was
just Bowser and practically stole the
show whenever he was voicing Bowser in
the Super Mario Brothers movie I'm very
curious about everything they're going
to do this villain chameleon uh seems
formidable and a shape-shifting type of
villain adds something fresh to the
franchise I feel and it's Viola Davis
who is a phenomenal actor as well and
she can be really scary in liveaction so
you know just bringing that presence
exuding Through The Voice work I can
only imagine she'll still bring that
intimidation factor I felt like ah God
what is the name oh my God the villain
the second villain was my f like every a
lot of people prefer taong but my
favorite villain was the second one what
is that guy's name the bir um anyway I'm
forgetting right now Shen is it Shen let
me just looking up it is Shen okay all
right you thought I couldn't pull it but
I didn't and then you know the
interaction between uh aquafina's
character Zen
it looks like it'll be a really fun one
with comedic and actionpack
sensibilities like one would expect and
I think Aquafina is a a wonderful voice
edition Talent just KIU Kuan is is
another great exceptional talent to
provide to the Kung Fu Panda Legacy as
well Tai long I feel like they might be
setting up for a Redemption Arc of sorts
feel like it might just be too
repetitive if they just brought them
back to be villainous yet again and if
you're going to bring back your your
first movies villain I think you got to
you know make it a little bit exciting
by doing something creatively different
as opposed to just you know Cameo
excitement but you know it's the Kung Fu
Panda franchise and all the like the
third one I really really liked a lot it
is my least favorite of the three I
really like the movie A Lot the first
two I absolutely love and I trust in
this creative team very much so this
franchise has a really strong Legacy the
fourth one has a lot to live up to I
love the fact that they got Han Zimmer
back to do the score yet again there's a
lot I'm really looking forward to this
overall uh yeah I'm excited for the film
man what do you guys think about the
trailer leave your thoughts down below
probably going to react to it right here
on this channel yeah let me let me get
to putting this video together for you
all thank you again for being here and
we'll talk with you all soon reject
[Music]
Nation